good morning john i just discovered that
the way people used to ask the science
side of tumblr questions people very
very occasionally ask the science side
of twitter questions so i just searched
for science side of twitter and i'm
going to answer as many questions as
they can in four minutes are
constellations different in the southern
hemisphere like is the big dipper and
the zodiac down there the constellations
themselves don't change but you can see
different ones depending on where you
are on earth if you were on the north
pole and the earth's axis weren't tilted
then you could only ever see just the
top half of the constellations and same
for the south pole now it's a little
complicated because it's tilting so your
perspective actually changes a little
bit throughout the year but if you're
right on the equator as the year goes by
you can actually see almost all of the
sky though a lot of it will be really
close to the horizon so hard to see if
you find this confusing it's because
it's very confusing the earth is
revolving while it's rotating and we're
also thinking about us being in
different places on a rotating and
revolving thing there are some people
who get their heads all the way around
this but they think about it for a
living how do i stop look i don't know i
have been told that you need an equal
and opposite force i haven't found one
yet but i have been assured that they
exist what are these giant quasar
looking stars though that's just a star
that is in our galaxy all those
background things in this image those
are galaxies that are like billions of
miles away so it's literally millions of
times closer so it looks a lot brighter
and super bright stuff when seen by the
james webb space telescope has these
diffraction spikes which is caused by
the shape of the mirror how many
calories on average do you burn taking a
massive dump i mean not zero
interestingly the anus is a muscle that
is almost always contracting um and so
it's always burning energy until it is
loosened in that case it's burning less
energy but i think that that's more than
outweighed by a lot of other muscle
contractions that are probably going on
during the dump plus you know any
anxiety you might be experiencing i
might also burn a little extra calories
why does ketchup have to be refrigerated
isn't it primarily vinegar salt and
sugar all of which are preservative
fascinating question when we talk about
preserving foods we're talking about two
different things one is preventing
bacteria from growing in it which is
going to spoil it and make it dangerous
high concentrations of vinegar salt and
sugar will all prevent bacterial growth
but we are also concerned about the
complicated molecules in the food stuff
breaking down into other molecules that
might just taste less good once the
ketchup is exposed to a good deal of
oxygen those reactions are going to
happen more quickly and so we want to
slow them down and one way to do that is
by having less heat in the system so
putting it in the refrigerator hey
science twitter any tips for reducing
eye strain when using a microscope using
a microscope is absolutely a lot of this
which is like hunch and eye stream so i
suggest you get one of these which the
micro cosmos microscope comes with it's
a cell phone holder you put the eyepiece
in here and then you clamp your cell
phone in here and you put it on and
you're looking through your microscope
like there's a screen now you do have to
be able to choose which lens your cell
phone is looking through which the
iphone doesn't let you do by default
there are apps that let you do that
though the one i use is called procam
and this one is specifically for me how
did i get an actual brain freeze without
consuming any liquids purely from
pouring cold water over my face so a
brain freeze is a kind of nerve pain
it's your brain misinterpreting a
confusing signal getting suddenly cold
will cause all the blood vessels near
your nerves to contract and then when
they warm back up very quickly they will
open back up and that will cause a flood
of blood to the area that will just be
confusing to the nervous system and in
your face and head all these sensory
nerves are really closely packed
together so it's just more common for
signals to get confused i think i
haven't heard of this happening before
but it totally seems like something that
could happen does sound travel in outer
space sound is just a bunch of molecules
slapping into each other so you need a
bunch of molecules really densely packed
together to carry that signal in an
atmosphere we have that this is actually
pretty thick soup of molecules right
here in space there are basically no
molecules so they can't knock into each
other to carry sound which is a good
thing because the sun is so energetic
that if space carried sound as well as
our atmosphere it would be a constant
100 decibel roar that we would never not
experience what's a good time to wake up
my friends because my phone is dying and
i need my charger block from their room
what you're gonna want to do is get two
potatoes and a copper wire and i'm
kidding i've just looked at your tweet
from 2 27 a.m you don't need to be on
twitter anymore bedtime it's bedtime
john i'll see you on tuesday